- The notion that we are
not enough, is a lie.
It's important for us to remember
the joy in what we do.
I was terrified to pursue
acting as a career.
I really didn't think
that this was kind of
an industry that I had what
it takes to compete in.
- She's an American actress
who rose to prominence
for starring in ABCs drama, Scandal.
For her work in Scandal she was nominated
for an Emmy Award at the 65th and 66th
primetime Emmy Awards.
In 2014, Time Magazine included her
in their Time 100 list.
She's Kerry Washington,
and here's my take on her
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is a personal favorite.
I'd make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Kerry is talking,
if she says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(light music)
- The notion that we are
not enough, is a lie.
And I think more young
people need to know that.
That like when you have that thought
that you're not enough,
that that's based on a lie
that somebody said to you,
or a lie that somebody did to you.
Like somebody said or did something to you
to make you feel like you're not enough,
and that's not true.
That you are everything
that you need to be.
That you have everything
that you need to have
to be the person that you're meant to be,
and to be the best version
of who you're meant to be.
It may mean that you
have to work really hard,
and it may mean that you
have to ask for help,
but you are perfectly blessed.
You know, you are exactly
who you're supposed to be
to be joyful in this life.
So don't be afraid to work hard,
and don't be afraid to ask for help
so you can get there.
'Cause that's your truth.
I had a yoga teacher who said to me,
"Always stay on your own yoga mat.
"Because sometimes if you're in headstand,
"and you're too busy looking at the person
"on the other mat,
"you could literally break your neck."
(laughs)
I feel like that's a really
good metaphor for life.
To stay on your own path,
do what's right for you.
You can't compare your insides
with somebody else's outsides,
because you never know what's going on
for somebody else, really.
- You don't have a lot of free time
to do other stuff, do you?
- No I don't.
- Have there been situations
where there was something
that you really wanted to do, movie wise,
or any other part that you
just weren't able to do
because of your schedule?
- Yeah, it's come up a couple times.
But that's the commitment you make,
particularly when you're
doing a network show.
You kind of have to be willing
to let some other stuff go.
And it's helped me to really focus
so that the projects
that I do during hiatus,
like the movie I'm
going to do this season,
is something I'm really,
really passionate about,
because I only have one
window to do something else,
so it has to be something
that means a lot to me.
I got great advice from,
one of the people that totally
fascinates me is Bob Iger,
he's the CEO of the Walt Disney ABC world,
so his job is so weird to
me 'cause he is in charge
of everything from like a Disney cruise
to George Stephanopoulos ABC News,
like he, to like a theme park to Scandal,
like all of that falls
into the ABC Disney family,
and I asked him, and it
was very helpful to me,
I asked him a few months ago,
like how do you decide what
you're going to work on in a day?
And he said something so valuable to me,
so I want to share it with you guys.
He said 80% of his time,
he tries to think about
where can I have impact?
Where am I going to make a difference
in the day to day?
So it may not usually be Disney cruises,
but sometimes it needs to be,
because the cruise business has been doing
what the cruise business is doing.
That's not quoting him, by the way.
(laughter)
But there, you know,
sometimes it's a Broadway show
that's about to open,
sometimes it's the ESPYs,
'cause ESPN, that's where
his focus needs to be.
So it's really about like
where can I have impact today,
and the other, where am I needed?
The other 20% is what brings me joy.
You know, so there are
certain movie projects
that fall under the ABC Disney
world that bring him joy,
or certain shows, or an opening of a park.
There are certain things that bring him,
that just fill him up
that fall in his work responsibilities.
And I just really have
tried to bring that with me
because it's important for us to remember
the joy in what we do.
It's important to be
effective in our workplace,
but it's important to
cultivate the moments
that just bring us joy.
Because that's how we'll shine
in our lives as professionals.
I joke around that I think
about quitting the business
at least once a year.
- Wow.
- Because it's tough.
And I know there's been
a lot of talk about
your misery being your message,
and for me it has really
been that I have to be
willing to go into the
places that scare me,
in order for God to be able to use me.
- Wow.
- So that's often what my job asks of me,
and sometimes I get tired
and talk about quitting,
but then God puts another
wonderful project in front of me
and I think, alright,
I guess I'm back at it.
- Here we go.
- Yeah.
There was a period before Scandal
when I went into the wilderness.
And for me what that meant was,
there was a lot of toxicity in my life.
People that I needed to let go of
in a personal way, in a business way.
And also I felt like I
had been living my career
kind of on auto pilot,
and I took a break and
did a Broadway play,
and I went back to my roots as an artist.
And doing Broadway is not
going to make you rich,
I think it cost me money
to do the play on Broadway,
but it was my return
to my artistic essence,
kind of the conversation
between audience and artist.
And I worked with a director
who really challenged me.
And so going into the
wilderness really meant
stripping myself of a lot of
unnecessary weight in my life.
And the ritual of doing theater is,
I thought of it as going into a monastery,
because you do the same
thing eight times a week,
in the same place, you say the same words,
with the same props,
and so it is a ritual that you commit to
and I just wanted to, in a monk-like way,
commit to that ritual and
let it teach me about myself,
and let myself unfold.
And in that period I let
go of a lot of people,
and a lot of things.
I experienced a lot of
loss professionally.
I had, for example, companies
that I was working with
on an endorsement level
that walked away from me,
because not everybody loves,
not everything is Broadway sexy.
And my personal life changed a great deal.
I allowed myself to be open
to change in my personal life.
I don't talk about my
personal life very often,
but that's true.
So I think going into the
wilderness made me ready,
as an artist, as a person,
as a business woman,
to receive Scandal.
- Who are your mentors in this business.
I mean Shanda, obviously, you
guys have worked together,
but backstage we were talking about,
you met with Cicely Tyson.
- Yeah.
- And you were just like, oh!
- Oh my gosh, yes.
I mean I have heroes.
Heroes of mine are,
you know, Cicely Tyson,
and Diahann Carroll, Rita
Moreno, Barbra Streisand,
I mean women who have just kind of said,
you know, oh I don't fit
your conventional idea
of what a superstar looks like?
Too bad, you know.
- I'm going to be one anyway.
- Yeah exactly, I'm going to do me.
And those women have
been real heroes of mine.
Mentors, Shanda's a big one,
Jane Fonda is a big mentor of mine,
and she's somebody who
really beautifully combines
her politics and activism with her work.
I don't know how many people know this but
the movie 9 to 5 resulted in
the union for secretaries.
There had been no union for
administrative assistants,
and that movie sort of
brought to light the need
because of abuse in
the workplace of women.
And that to me is always
a shining example of
using art and really great, fun art,
to better the world.
So she's a real mentor of mine.
Eva Ensler, who's the writer
of the Vagina Monologues.
Yeah, um, yeah.
If I can really show up for
life, with my imperfections,
we give each other permission
to be human when we show up.
When we hide under the
covers and feel like
I have to be perfect,
I have to look perfect,
I have to do perfect,
then we rob each other of community.
It's in our truth, in our imperfections,
in our beauties, in our
flaws, in our strengths.
That's where we find strength together.
That's when we're honest.
- Yes.
- So, listen.
I mean even, I know when
you look at Olivia Pope,
you are seeing a team at work.
I sat in that hair and
make-up chair for hours.
You know, I didn't roll out
of bed to be Olivia Pope.
There's somebody who gets
paid all day to brush my hair.
So, you know, people,
and I think it's important
for me to say that,
because it's a disservice
for you to feel like
you have to look like your
hair is laid all day long.
Like literally, somebody
is in a hair union,
following me around with
a brush and some hairspray
all day so that Olivia
Pope's hair is laid.
- And it is.
- Well she's good, Linda's
good, Linda's good.
I mean, you can't deny Linda's good.
So that's, it's important
for us to talk about that,
because I don't look like
that when I go to Whole Foods,
you know what I mean?
I don't bring Linda
with me to Whole Foods.
I go to Whole Foods with
my little hair band,
and it's up in a bun,
and let's roll and get some apples.
So I think it's important that we sort of
frame our expectations, and know that,
I know for me to show up as the character,
I want to have all those pieces in place
to inspire and to have a creative moment,
but I am not Olivia Pope,
and I'm just Kerry.
I was terrified to pursue
acting as a career.
I really didn't think that
this was kind of an industry
that I had what it takes to compete in.
Because I didn't, and I don't necessarily
have a drive toward fame.
It's not something that
really calls to me,
and so I just thought,
well I'll never make it,
'cause I'm not one of those girls
that wants to be on the
cover of every magazine,
like I just really love to act.
And it wasn't until I found out
about the existence of actor's unions,
and knowing what unions
mean in our country
and in our history, I just thought,
oh well, if there are unions for actors
then that must mean there
are thousands of people
who are making a living
doing what they love to do,
even if they're never famous,
so maybe I'll give it a try.
- We're going to play dance charades,
and I'm going to give you
45 seconds to show me how,
'cause I think you'll
be a very good dancer,
and I like to play games.
- I like to dance.
- So we'll go over here,
and let's see what we have, over here.
(applause)
Move on the other side.
- When you said dance for you
I wasn't sure what you meant.
- Yeah, no, no, I don't have
any dollar bills in my pants.
- Okay, alright.
I thought she was going to make it rain!
- No, no.
(laughs)
Somebody get me some dollar bills.
(laughter, applause)
Alright, so you have 45
seconds on the clock.
- Okay.
- I'll hold up the card.
I'm going to have to guess what you're...
- Okay, alright.
- Ready?
- Yes.
- 45 seconds on the clock, go.
- Oh, okay, ready.
- Gandnam Style.
- Yes!
- Vogue.
- Waltzing, Flamenco dancing,
that is a kind of dance.
- Yeah.
It's ballroom dancing.
And I pass.
And it's Tango, damn.
Sorry, 'kay.
Oh, I should know the name of that.
Running man?
- Uh-huh.
- Tap?
It's like clogging, or
Scottish dancing, or,
- Yes.
- Yeah something like that.
Yeah, what's this.
- Uh, okay.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Single ladies.
- Yes!
(applause, cheering)
- You think that I'm bad.
Peeples is in theaters now.
Go see it, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
- I'm here with the one and
only Kerry Washington right now,
and we are about to play Box of Lies.
Here's how it works.
Upstage there are a bunch of boxes
containing objects neither
of us have seen before.
Taking turns, Kerry and I
are going to select a box
and open it on our side of the table,
out of the view of the other person.
Once the object is out of the box,
you look at your opponent and
tell them what's in the box.
You might be lying, you
might be telling the truth.
Your opponent has to guess which one
and say either lie, or truth.
(laughter)
If you guess correctly, you get a point.
If you guess wrong, the
other person gets a point.
First to two points wins.
Kerry, you're our guest, why
don't you pick your first box?
- Thanks Jim.
- You're welcome.
(audience yelling)
Oh, got a little heft to it.
Hint number one.
(Jimmy humming)
(laughter)
- In my box,
is a pumpkin with spaghetti in it.
(laughter, clapping)
- What?
(laughs)
Why are you laughing?
Pumpkin with pasgetti on it.
- Spaghetti.
- Yeah, I wanted to see if you're acting.
(laughter)
You lie!
- No!
It's true!
- What?
(cheering)
Let me see it.
(applause)
oh you're good, you're good.
Let me pick one.
(audience yelling)
Three!
- What's in the box, Jimmy?
- Oh I don't know.
- What's in your box, Jimmy?
- Ah, well, well, well.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- In my box, is an iPhone 6.
- Plus, or regular?
- Plus.
With a figurine getting a
tattoo from another figurine,
that I believe to be Justin Bieber.
That is what is in my box.
- That's a lie.
- You got me.
(cheering, applause)
Wait, you won!
It was that fast?
You are too good at this.
Kerry Washington, the champ!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Delta Horse Races asked me to.
So it there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did she say that had
the biggest impact on you?
What lesson was most
important to you and why?
Please leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Jason Fonceca and Yuki,
thank you guys so much
for going to the bookstore
and picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Your life is your story,
and the adventure ahead of you
is the journey to fulfill your
own purpose and potential.
So I want to share a little
something with you about stories,
and about heroes, and
about how this all works.
It was here at GW that I first
read the work of Joseph Campbell.
And what attracted me to his writing
was the concept of the hero's journey.
He wrote, "The hero's journey
always begins with the call.
"One way or another a guide
must come and say look,
"you're in sleepy land.
"Awake, come on a trip.
"There is an aspect of your
consciousness, your being,
"that's not being touched.
"And so it starts."
This call to adventure
is what we call in film
the inciting incident.
It's an invitation out
of your comfort zone,
and into your strength.
Because by definition, being
a hero requires pushing beyond
the bounds of what's comfortable.
In 1996 in my junior year here,
I had to push beyond the
bound of my comfort zone.
The musical that year, which as you know,
I was required to audition for,
was entitled, Croak, The Last Frog.
It was a beautiful musical about frogs
by GW's own Professor Leslie Jacobsen.
Now,
(cheering)
I have to be honest with you.
It was not my lifetime
dream role to play a frog.
In fact, the thought of it terrified me.
Scared that the role
would be too difficult,
and afraid of the embarrassment
that would result from my failed attempts,
I wondered if there was some way
that I could get out of this audition.
This is what Campbell describes as
phase two of the hero's journey,
the refusal of the call.
You've experienced it,
an exciting opportunity presents itself,
but our fear makes us believe
that we're not capable
of meeting the challenge.
There are 17 stages of the hero's journey
as Campbell describes it but don't worry,
I'm not going to go through all of them.
What I will tell you is
that I crossed the threshold
into unknown territory, meaning,
I showed up for my audition
because I believed in the
message of the production.
A message of love, and family,
and environmental conservation.
I wanted to support Leslie Jacobsen,
my brilliant professor and my mentor,
and I had to fulfill my
scholarship requirements,
because, as many of
you probably relate to,
I wanted to complete
my degree and graduate.
So I answered the call.
I pushed past my comfort zone,
and when I did, I won the role.
So now I was in the belly of the whale.
Now I had to be willing
to be the lead frog.
Again, I was terrified.
This was a serious musical
with important dramatic themes.
How could I commit to the role
and bring life to the character
in a way that made people think and feel,
rather than giggle and mock us.
So I approached the role
as a social scientist,
the way GW taught me to.
I thought, I'm going to study frogs.
I went to the zoo up in Woodley Park
and I spent hours watching frogs.
I read about frogs, I held frogs,
I watched frog documentaries,
I figured out ways to physicalize
my performance as a frog
without seeming to be a cartoon.
I faced my fears and I stepped out onto
that Marvin Center stage,
(cheering)
and it became a role that
transformed my thinking
about how I use my body to do
what I do every single day,
and more importantly, to this day,
it is my father's most
favorite thing I've ever done.
I'm serious, you can ask him.
(applause)
But the lesson here isn't
how you too, can be a frog,
the lesson is that you
are sitting here today
because you too, learned
how to answer the call.
Your degree is proof that
you have what it takes
to take the leap into the adventure
of your unique experience.
You don't earn a degree
by doing, and being,
and existing in the comfort zone
of what you already know.
So whether it's taken two years or seven
to get today's degree,
I want you to look back on the journey
that brought you here.
What moments challenged you most?
When were you asked to step outside of
your familiar territory in order to
rise to the occasion of your potential?
How have you pushed past your fear?
I want you to remember those moments
because they will embolden you,
and affirm you, and remind
you that you did this.
You completed this journey.
You answered the call.
And now you can continue to do so,
but the choice is yours.
When you leave here today
and commence the next stage of your life,
you can follow someone else's script,
try to make choices that
will make other people happy,
avoid discomfort, do what is expected,
and copy the status quo.
Or, you can look at all that
you have accomplished today,
and use it as fuel to venture forth
and write your own story.
If you do, amazing things will take shape.